Thank you for listening to The Rest is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is, therestishistory.com. Ooh, nice! Air Canada has a worldwide sale. Wow, look at this deal to the Philippines. Nice, let's book it. But wait, Naples is also a steal. Saving seafood and sun? You want sun?
感谢收听《历史的余烬》。如果您想收听每周的独家加更节目、无广告音频、提前解锁系列节目，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。哦，太棒了！加拿大航空正在进行全球大促销。哇，你看去菲律宾的这个优惠。不错，我们订票吧。等等，去那不勒斯的机票也是白菜价。想要海鲜和阳光？你想要阳光？
There's a hot deal to Mexico. And even hotter to Yellowknife. Nice, but I thought you wanted tropical hot. You're all over the map. Well, yeah, we've got over 180 destinations to choose from. Saving on every single destination. Nice. Hurry, book at AirCanada.com or contact your travel agent.
去墨西哥有超值优惠。去耶洛奈夫的优惠力度更大。不错，但我以为你想要热带的热。你这盘棋下得也太散了。好吧，是的，我们有 180 多个目的地供您选择。每个目的地都有优惠。太好了。赶快行动，在 AirCanada.com 预订或联系您的旅行社。
Conditions apply. Air Canada, Nice travels. Suddenly, looking towards the forest, the duke saw glimpses of English columns and a great glittering of spears. Spilling out from the trees there came troops of men and then, emerging into full view, an entire army. There was a hill near the forest, set beside a valley, and the ground had been left untilled because the terrain was so rough.
须遵守相关条款。加拿大航空，一路精彩旅行。突然，公爵朝森林望去，隐约看到一列列英国士兵和如林般闪烁的长矛。成队的士兵从树林中涌出，随后，整支军队完全展现在人们眼前。森林附近有一座小山，紧邻着一个山谷，由于地形过于崎岖，这片土地一直荒废着。
Advancing in massed order, which is the English custom, they seized possession of this place and readied for battle. Ignorant of war as they are, the English scorned to ride horses, preferring instead to trust in their strength and stand fast on foot, and they counted the highest honour to die in arms in defence of their native soil so as to prevent any foreign yoke being imposed upon it. The King of the English, preparing to meet the enemy, climbed the hill and strengthened both his wings with noble men. On the very summit of the hill he planted his banner and ordered his other standards
他们以密集的队形前进，这是英格兰人的习俗，他们占据了这个地方并准备战斗。英格兰人对战争一无所知，他们不屑于骑马，而是更愿意将希望寄托于自己的力量，坚守在步兵阵地上，他们认为为保卫祖国而战死沙场是最高的荣誉，这样才能防止任何异族统治强加于其上。英格兰国王为迎战敌人，登上了小山，并用贵族士兵加强了两翼。他在山顶竖起了自己的旗帜，并命令其他军旗
as well to be set up. All his men dismounted and left their horses in the rear. And then, taking their stand on foot, they let the trumpets sound for battle. So that's a source called The Song of the Battle of Hastings, probably written within months of the battle, and we'll come back to exactly what that source is. But listeners who have stuck with us through this mighty series will remember that last time we followed the heart-stopping, blood-curdling drama of Harold Hardrada's invasion of Northern England and we heard how Hardrada was cut down and killed at the Battle of Stamford Bridge
也一并竖起。所有人下马，把战马留在后方。然后，他们步行坚守阵地，吹响了战斗的号角。这就是被称为《黑斯廷斯战役之歌》的资料来源，它可能是在战役结束几个月内写成的，我们稍后会回过头来详细讨论这个资料来源。但一直陪伴我们走过这个宏大系列的听众会记得，上次我们追踪了哈罗德·哈德拉达入侵英格兰北部那扣人心弦、惊心动魄的戏剧性事件，我们听说了哈德拉达是如何在斯坦福桥战役中被斩杀身亡的
by the English King Harold Godwinson, formerly Earl of Wessex, in one of the greatest victories ever won by Anglo-Saxon, or indeed English, arms. So Tom, Stamford Bridge was the 25th of September, and we heard how at the turn of October, Harold heard the terrible news of the landing of William of Normandy. And so now less than three weeks later, he is at, or just outside Hastings. And he is facing another mighty epoch defining showdown. So it's the 14th of October. He is of course facing William of Normandy and what follows is the most famous and arguably the single most decisive battle
凶手是英格兰国王哈罗德·戈德温森（前韦塞克斯伯爵），这是盎格鲁-撒克逊人（或者说英格兰人）军队赢 得的最伟大的胜利之一。所以汤姆，斯坦福桥战役发生在 9 月 25 日，我们听说在 10 月初转折之际，哈罗德听到了诺曼底公爵威廉登陆的恐怖消息。因此，不到三周后的现在，他已经身处黑斯廷斯或其郊外。他正面临另一场决定时代的强大决战。现在是 10 月 14 日。他面对的自然是诺曼底公爵威廉，接下来将发生的是英格兰历史上最著名、可以说是最具决定性的一场战役
in all English history. Absolutely. And the one I would say that is most familiar probably to anyone who has even the faintest interest in history in England, certainly. And scenes from the battle will be familiar to most people who live in this country. The idea of the English battle lion on Senlac Hill, this great hill outside Hastings, the Normans serried in their armour on their horses at the foot of the hill, the Norman knights charging the English shield wall, King Harold as the shadows lengthen over the battlefield as the sun sets in the west, struck
整个英格兰历史上。绝对是这样。而且我要说，对于在英格兰哪怕只有一点点历史兴趣的人来说，这也是最熟悉的一场。对于生活在这个国家的大多数人来说，战役中的场景也会非常熟悉。森拉克山上的英格兰战狮——黑斯廷斯郊外这座巨大的小山、诺曼人在山脚下列队披甲骑马、诺曼骑士冲向英格兰盾墙、随着战场上阴影拉长、太阳在西方落下，哈罗德国王被
by an arrow in the eye. And the accounts of the battle that we have, you mentioned one, possibly written only a few months after Harold's death, are detailed and vivid in a way that the sources for Stamford Bridge simply aren't. So we talked in the previous episode how King Harold's saga, the great account by Snorrius Sturluson dates to almost two centuries after 1066. But we have accounts of Hastings that are incredibly close to
一箭射中眼睛。我们现有的关于这场战役的记述——你提到的其中一篇可能是在哈罗德死后几个月内写成的——其详细和生动程度是斯坦福桥战役的资料根本无法比拟的。我们在上一集中谈到过，斯诺里·斯蒂松所著的伟大著作《哈罗德国王传奇》可追溯到 1066 年之后的将近两个世纪。但我们对黑斯廷斯的记录却极其接近
the battle. So most famously we have the Bay of Tapestry, which is not a tapestry, but a great embroidered cloth over 200 feet long. And it illuminates not just the battle, but the events leading up to it. We've already had reference to it and indeed to its aftermath. And another source we've also already mentioned in this series, William of Poitiers, who had served William as a soldier before becoming his chaplain and he gives again a detailed account. But as you said, amazingly, we have an account that is even more contemporary, probably written
这场战役。最著名的当属《巴约挂毯》，它其实不是挂毯，而是一块长达 200 多英尺的大型刺绣布。它不仅展现了战役本身，还描绘了导致战役发生的事件。我们之前已经提到过它以及它的后续影响。我们在这个系列中已经提到过的另一个资料来源是普瓦捷的威廉，他在成为威廉的随军牧师之前曾作为士兵为威廉服役，他也提供了详细的记述。但正如你所说，令人惊叹的是，我们甚至有一份更具当代色彩的记述，可能写于
in around Easter 1067, so fewer than six months after the battle. And for a long while, the authenticity of the Carmen, the song of the Battle of Hastings was furiously debated. It kind of appeared almost from nowhere in the 19th century, and there were lots of people who thought it might have been a medieval fake. But I think it's now pretty widely accepted to have been written by a bishop who served William's wife, Matilda, as her chaplain. So we have these two chaplains, William of Poitiers and this bishop who wrote the Carmen. And this enables us to get up close to the build up the actual events, the aftermath of Hastings in a way that, well, I mean, to quote Michael Lawson, whose book on the battle
大约 1067 年的复活节，也就是战役结束后不到六个月。很长一段时间里，关于《卡门》（即《黑斯廷斯战役之歌》）的真实性曾引发激烈的争论。它在 19 世纪几乎凭空出现，许多人认为它可能是中世纪的伪造品。但我认为现在人们普遍接受它是威廉的妻子马蒂尔德的随军牧师、一位主教所写的。所以我们有这两位随军牧师，普瓦捷的威廉和这位写了《卡门》的主教。这使我们能够近距离地了解黑斯廷斯战役的酝酿、实际经过以及后续发展，其程度——嗯，借用迈克尔·洛森的话说，他对这场战役的研究
is probably the best one that there is, he's written about it, the more is known about Hastings than any battle fought in the West since the end of the Roman Empire. But inevitably, having said that, there are caveats. So all those things that people think they know about the Battle of Hastings. Did the English really confine themselves to just standing on a hill? Did the Norman knights really charge the shield wall? Was Harold really slain by an arrow hitting his eye? I mean, as we will find out, these are all issues that are furiously debated. And so to match that quotation from Michael Lawson about us knowing more about Hastings than any battle since the end of the Roman Empire, here's one from John Gillingham.
可能是现存最好的著作，他曾写道，人们对黑斯廷斯的了解超过了自罗马帝国灭亡以来西方发生的任何一场战役。但话虽如此，难免还是有些疑问。人们以为自己对黑斯廷斯战役了解的那些事情，真的如此吗？英格兰人真的只是固守山头吗？诺曼骑士真的冲锋冲击了盾墙吗？哈罗德真的被射中眼睛身亡吗？正如我们将要发现的，这些都是激烈争论的议题。为了呼应迈克尔·洛森关于我们对黑斯廷斯的了解超过罗马帝国灭亡以来任何战役的说法，这里还有约翰·吉林厄姆的一句话。
Almost the only thing about the Norman conquest that isn't controversial is the fact that the Normans won the Battle of Hastings. So there is lots to discuss. So I mean, the version that I grew up with, you know, that we studied at school, was very dramatic. The Normans charge, Harold is hit by the arrow, all of these great excitements, but they're all in the balance, aren't they? So that's the fascinating thing. I think the alternative theories are just as exciting and thrilling. Right. There's no question. This is an extraordinary, terrifying, bloody conflict. No doubt about that.
关于诺曼征服，几乎唯一没有争议的事实就是诺曼人赢得了黑斯廷斯战役。因此有许多事情需要讨论。我当年在学校学到的版本非常戏剧化：诺曼人冲锋，哈罗德中箭，所有这些伟大的刺激情节，但它们其实都悬而未决，不是吗？这才是最迷人的地方。我认为其他的替代理论也同样激动人心、惊心动魄。没错。毫无疑问，这是一场非同寻常、极其恐怖、血腥的冲突。这是毫无疑问的。
It's just that some of the details are up for debate and we'll be looking at them. Okay. So let's pick up from where we left off with William before. So before we got into the story of Harold Hardrada, listeners may remember that we left William. He gathered his forces. He is this great name. He's a great drawer. He's got people from all over France, hasn't he, to join his, I was
只是其中的一些细节尚存争议，我们将对此进行探讨。好的。那么让我们接着之前的内容，继续谈威廉。在我们深入讲述哈罗德·哈德拉达的故事之前，听众可能还记得我们当时把威廉晾在了一边。他集结了部队。他是个大人物，极具号召力。他招募了来自法国各地的人来加入他的——我
about to say his crusade and it does have a little bit of that quality. Slight quality. Yeah. Right. But he's been kicking his heels in frustration on the coast of Normandy because as this Carmen, this song describes, storms and ceaseless rain prevented his fleet from making the crossing. And obviously Harold had decided that William wasn't coming. So what changes? Well I imagine that the
本来想说他的十字军东征，这确实有点那种性质。略微有点。是的。没错。但他却 frustating 地在诺曼底海岸急得直跺脚，因为正如这首《卡门》所描述的那样，风暴和连绵不断的阴雨阻碍了他的舰队渡海。显然，哈罗德已经认定威廉不会来了。那么是什么改变了局势？嗯，我想
news that Harold across the Channel in England has stood down his men has reached William and it's four days after Harold has sent his men back to get the harvest in and so on. On the 8th of September, on the 12th of September, William decides, I think that this is too good an opportunity to miss, even though the winds are still against him. And so he orders his fleet on the 12th of September to leave port and to sail out into the channel. But these winds, as we've said, are still contrary. They're still very, very difficult to navigate. And people may remember that Harold had sent his fleet back to London and it gets caught up in a terrible storm and large numbers of ships are shipwrecked. It
海峡对岸英格兰的哈罗德让部队解散的消息已经传到了威廉耳中，这发生在哈罗德派士兵回家收割庄稼等事宜的四天后。9月8日、9月12日，威廉认为，即使当时风向对己方不利，这也是一个不容错过的绝佳机会。于是他在 9 月 12 日下令舰队出港，驶入海峡。但正如我们所说，这些风向依然逆风。航行依然非常非常困难。人们可能还记得，哈罗德曾把舰队派回伦敦，结果遭遇了可怕的风暴，大量船只触礁沉没。看来
seems that the same storms that damage Harold's fleet so badly blows Williams off course. Some of his ships are wrecked and the vast body of the fleet have to take refuge not in an English port, but in a port further up the French coast. So specifically a place called St. Valerie-sur-Somme. So that's north of Normandy itself. And it is closer to the English coast than William had previously been, but it is still separated from England by kind of 50 miles of storm-lashed seas. And William is chastened, I think, by the near disaster that his fleet has suffered. And so he decides he's not going to risk that anymore and the contrary winds blow for a further fortnight. You know, and this is a huge problem.
摧毁哈罗德舰队的那场可怕风暴也把威廉的舰队吹离了航线。他的一些船只失事，主力舰队不得不避难，不是在英格兰港口，而是在法国海岸更上游的一个港口。具体来说，是一个叫圣瓦勒里叙索姆的地方。那是诺曼底以北。它比威廉之前所在的位置更接近英格兰海岸，但它仍然与英格兰隔着大约 50 英里风暴肆虐的海域。威廉因舰队遭遇的近乎灾难的险情而受到了打击，我想。因此他决定不再冒险，而逆风又刮了两周之久。你知道，这是一个巨大的问题。
He's no longer in Normandy for a start. So he can't command resources in the way that he'd been able to do previously. He's lost lots of his ships. His supplies are running out. There's all that issue with getting rid of the horses urine, all that kind of stuff. So it's an incredible tribute, I think think to his powers of leadership that he does seem able to hold this expedition together. But you can imagine him, well in fact he's described as looking up at the weather cock on top of the church in St. Valerie, kind of just waiting for the winds to change. And do you think he knows that Harold has dispersed the feared? Do you think he knows that he sent his army back to get the harvest? I'm sure he must have done. Right. It seems
首先，他已经不在诺曼底了。所以他无法像以前那样调配资源。他失去了许多船只。他的补给正在耗尽。还有处理战马尿液等所有诸如此类的问题。因此，他似乎能够将这支远征军凝聚在一起，这绝对证明了他非凡的领导力。但你可以想象他——事实上，书中描述他抬头看着圣瓦勒里教堂顶上的风向标，静静地等待风向改变。你觉得他知道哈罗德解散了民兵吗？你觉得他知道哈罗德把军队派回老家收庄稼了吗？他肯定知道。没错。这似乎是
the only explanation for why he would have risked sailing out four days after Harold had done that. And also it might be hard to muster another force a year's time people like what they didn't even go the first time and not going again. Yeah, I mean, I think he absolutely feels you know, it's now or never. And so on the 27th of September, at last, the weathercock turns, the winds have changed, the sea stands fair for England. And so William gives his men orders to embark and high tide, which is in the mid afternoon,
他为什么会在哈罗德那样做四天后冒险起航的唯一解释。而且，一年后也很难再拉起另一支军队，大家会觉得他们第一次都没去，这次也不会去了。是的，我的意思是，他绝对觉得，你知道，机不可失，失不再来。因此，在 9 月 27 日，风向标终于转动了，风向变了，通往英格兰的海面风平浪静。于是威廉下令部下登船，正值涨潮，大约在下午中段，
the horses are led up ramps onto the transport ships. The Carmen describes William's men rushing to take their places like a flock of doves heading to a dove cut. And just before sunset, the Norman fleet is ready to set sail and William's own flagship leads the way. And this is a ship called the Mora, which is a gift from his wife. The stern post has a wonderful figurehead, the figure of a boy blowing a trumpet. And we're told a lantern was slung high on the masthead as a guiding beacon and the sound of a horn signaled the advance. So William leads the fleet out into the darkening channel as the sun sets. And the Moorah is a very streamlined ship. And in fact, it's so swift that by next morning,
战马顺着跳板被牵引上运输船。据《卡门》描述，威廉的部下争先恐后地各就各位，就像一群飞向鸽舍的白鸽。就在日落前，诺曼舰队准备起航，威廉自己的旗舰带头领航。这是一艘名为“莫拉号”的船，是他的妻子赠送的。船尾柱上有一个精美的船头雕像，是一个吹号角的男孩的形象。据说桅杆顶端高高悬挂着一盏灯笼作为指引灯塔，号角声宣告了前进的信号。于是威廉率领舰队驶入日渐昏暗的海峡，夕阳西下。“莫拉号”是一艘流线型极佳的船。事实上，它速度极快，以至于第二天清晨，
as the sun rises over the channel to the east, William finds that he's completely on his own. He can't see any other ships. And rather than panic, he displays immense sangfroid. He has a hearty breakfast, which we're told he waters down with wine. And by the time he's finished it, he goes back up onto deck and there behind him is a great forest of masts. The Norman fleet is still with him and on they sail to England. So that story seems to me to have the veracity of some of those stories that you have from Harald Hardrada in the Icelandic sagas. I mean I know they're different literary traditions
当太阳在海峡东面升起时，威廉发现自己完全孤身一人。他看不到任何其他船只。但他没有惊慌，反而展现出极大的镇定。他吃了一顿丰盛的早餐，据说还兑了酒。吃完后，他回到甲板上，发现身后是一片密密麻麻的桅杆森林。诺曼舰队依然伴随着他，他们继续向英格兰驶去。在我看来，这个故事带有冰岛萨迦中哈罗德·哈德拉达那些故事的真实感。我知道它们是不同的文学传统，
but you know the commander forged on alone then he noticed that nobody was with him. But he didn't lose his cool. He drank a flag and a wine and then continued and soon his men caught him up. I mean, that feels like to me like, I think I've heard that story about 40 times about different people. I think the difference though, is that these are being told by people who were there or who were absolutely familiar with the details of the expedition. So you're like Arrian talking about Ptolemy when he met the talking snake in the desert. The king wouldn't lie and he was there.
但你知道，指挥官独自勇往直前，然后发现身边空无一人。但他没有慌乱。他喝了一大杯酒，然后继续前行，不久他的部下就赶上了他。我的意思是，这让我感觉——我想我大约听过 40 遍关于不同人物的这个故事。不过我认为不同之处在于，这些故事是由当时在场的人，或者对远征细节极其熟悉的人讲述的。就像阿里安谈到托勒密在沙漠中遇到会说话的蛇一样。国王不会撒谎，而且他当时就在场。
So I mean obviously it happened. No, because Arrian was writing centuries later, whereas these are people who are writing a few years later and are surrounded by people who'd been on the... But you're saying leave everything that they tell you. I think it's unlikely that they would just make up details that everyone would have been able to scoff at. Right. The details may be slightly spiced up. I think that probably the details we're getting from the Carmen and from William of Poitiers in the main are fairly accurate because there are so many people who'd be reading them that they would know if they weren't. Let's get to what we do know. So we definitely
所以这显然是发生了的。不，因为阿里安是几个世纪后写的，而这些人是在几年后写作，周围都是经历过……但你的意思是他们说的全盘皆信。我认为他们不太可能凭空捏造细节，因为所有人都会对之嗤之以鼻。没错。细节可能略有润色。我认为我们从《卡门》和普瓦捷的威廉那里得到的细节大体上相当准确，因为有那么多人在阅读，如果有假，他们会知道的。让我们来看看我们确实知道的事情。所以我们非常
know that they are heading for this natural harbour protected by a spit of land called Pevensey Bay and they arrive what, nine o'clock in the morning? Yep, and Pevensey Bay, it's a natural harbour, it's kind of lagoons really and it's tidal and it's protected by a spit of land that sticks out on the western side and on the western side there's a crumbling Roman fort and there's a little port and that's Pevensey itself. But there's a problem which is that Pevensey and this Roman fort, although the Normans are very quick to fortify and kind of boost the defenses, it's not easy to get from there to the main road that leads to London because essentially you have to ride all the way around the lagoon and it's about,
确定他们正驶向一个由名为佩文西湾的沙嘴保护的天然港湾，他们大约在什么时间到达？早上九点？是的，佩文西湾是一个天然港湾，实际上有点像泻湖，受潮汐影响，西侧突出的一个沙嘴对其起到了保护作用。在西侧有一座残破的罗马堡垒和一个小港口，那就是佩文西本身。但这里有一个问题：佩文西和这座罗马堡垒——尽管诺曼人很快就对其实行了要塞化并加强了防御——从那里很难到达通往伦敦的主路，因为基本上你必须绕着整个泻湖骑行，
you know, 20 odd miles to do that. So some of the ships are pulled up there, but there's the real sense that actually Pevensey itself is not a good base. And so what they do is start looking further East to the town of Hastings. Right. And Hastings is much more conveniently linked to London. So the main road from Hastings goes along a kind of high ridge and it's surrounded on either side by trees and then down by mudflats kind of leading down to the lagoon of Pevensey
你知道，大约有二十多英里远。所以有些船只被拉到了那里，但人们明显感觉到佩文西本身并不是一个好的基地。于是他们开始向东寻找黑斯廷斯镇。没错。黑斯廷斯与伦敦的交通要方便得多。从黑斯廷斯出发的主路沿着一道高高的山脊延伸，道路两侧被树林环绕，然后向下延伸到佩文西湾泻湖的泥滩，另一侧也是如此。所以它有点像一个半岛，威廉决定将这里作为他的基地，他和他的亲戚兼童年玩伴威廉·菲茨奥斯本在到达黑斯廷斯后，
Bay and on the other side as well. So it's kind of like a peninsula and William decides that he will make this his base and he and his relative and a childhood friend of his called William Fitz Osborne then having reached Hastings, reconnoitre the terrain and they realise very rapidly that Hastings is a kind of natural trap because it is open to attack from the sea. Equally, this single road leading northwards to London is so fringed on either side by creeks that it is the only way out from Hastings. There is no other way to escape it.
对地形进行了侦察，他们很快意识到黑斯廷斯其实是一个天然陷阱，因为它面向大海毫无遮挡。同样，这条向北通往伦敦的唯一道路，两侧被无数小海湾夹击，是离开黑斯廷斯的唯一通道。没有其他逃生路线。
And that in turn means that if there is an amphibious attack, so if Harold comes down along the road from London with his infantry and And if a naval force attacks Hastings from the south, then the Normans will be surrounded. So in lots of ways, it's an insane place for him to stay. William orders inevitably a castle to be built at Hastings. So the Normans have now built one at Pevensey, they've now built one at Hastings. And he sends his horsemen out to ravage the villages that surround Hastings. Hastings is in Sussex and Sussex is Harold's native county. So there's clearly good propaganda value to be had for William in burning down the villages that Harold properly should be
反过来这也意味着，如果有两栖攻击——也就是说，如果哈罗德带着步兵沿伦敦道路南下，而一支海军力量从南面攻击黑斯廷斯，那么诺曼人就会被包围。因此，在许多方面，留在这里是一个疯狂的决定。威廉不可避免地命令在黑斯廷斯修建一座城堡：诺曼人现在已经在佩文西建了一座，现在又在黑斯廷斯建了一座。他派出骑兵去蹂躏黑斯廷斯周围的村庄。黑斯廷斯在苏塞克斯，而苏塞克斯是哈罗德的家乡。因此，威廉纵容部下烧毁本该由哈罗德保护的村庄，显然具有很好的宣传价值。
defending. But it does seem kind of madness for the Normans to stay in Hastings because the risk of being trapped there is so enormous. And why, having brought all their horses, all this proficiency they have in building makeshift castles, why would they stay there? Why are they not spilling out across Sussex? Because they are massively risking a pitched battle if they do stay there. And the Norman way of war is to avoid battles. We'd mentioned William had only ever fought in one battle.
但诺曼人留在黑斯廷斯似乎近乎疯狂，因为被困在那里的风险太大了。为什么在带了所有战马、展现了如此建造临时城堡的熟练技巧之后，他们还要留在这里？为什么不向整个苏塞克斯扩散？因为如果他们留在那儿，就要冒着打一场遭遇战的巨大风险。而诺曼人的战争方式是避免打仗。我们曾提到威廉只打过一次仗。
And William of Poitiers describes the Norman way of war, that it is to strike fear by frequent lengthy expeditions across enemy territory, to lay waste harvests, fields and halls, to plant castles and garrisons wherever they would cause maximum damage, to overwhelm the enemy by engulfing him in a great multitude of troubles. And Harold, when he's brought the news of William's landing, he knows that is the Norman way of war. Okay, in that case, given that the Normans have this very tried and tested way of waging war that actually always works for them, why is William doing something so unorthodox?
普瓦捷的威廉描述了诺曼人的战争方式：通过频繁、长时间地对敌方领土进行远征来制造恐惧，摧毁庄稼、田野和大厅，无论在哪里能造成最大破坏就建立城堡和驻军，用铺天盖地的麻烦将敌人淹没。哈罗德在听到威廉登陆的消息时，他深知这就是诺曼人的战争方式。好吧，既然如此，鉴于诺曼人这种屡试不爽、对他们而言总是奏效的战争方式，威廉为什么要做出如此非正统的举动？
Why is he staying put and why is he not going and harrying everybody and building castles and laying waste to the countryside and all the stuff that he would normally do when he was fighting in France? I think it goes back to what we talked about in a previous episode that William knows the only way he can possibly secure the crown of England is by defeating and killing Harold in a pitched battle. And to draw Harold into a battle, he has to give Harold the serious prospect that he'll be able to wipe William out. So in a sense, what William is doing is offering himself and his army up as bait. And of course, it is a completely desperate gamble because he knows that he's staking everything he's
他为什么要呆在原地不动，为什么不去四处袭扰、建造城堡、摧毁乡村，以及做他在法国作战时通常会做的一切事情呢？我认为这可以追溯到我们在前一集里谈到的内容：威廉深知，他要稳坐英格兰王位，唯一的途径就是在正面的遭遇战中击败并杀死哈罗德。为了把哈罗德引诱到战场上，他必须给哈罗德一个切实的前景，让哈罗德觉得他有能力彻底消灭威廉。从某种意义上说，威廉是在将自己和他的军队当作诱饵。当然，这是一场极其绝望的赌博，因为他知道他正在押上自己统治生涯中所取得的一切成果。
achieved over the course of his rule. In fact, he's staking his own life, but he has invaded England in the conviction that God is on his side. And what he is aiming to do is to put that conviction to the test. And you really think that affects his strategy that he thinks because God is with me, I'm going to change the way I fight and risk everything on one throw the dice. Or do you think he just thinks the only way of doing this actually fight and risk everything on one throw the dice. Or do you think he just thinks the only way of doing this actually is to risk everything on one throw the dice and also God's with me. So that's brilliant too. Well, I think it's both.
事实上，他连自己的生命都押上了，但他入侵英格兰是坚信上帝站在他这一边。而他的目标就是对这一信念进行终极考验。你真的认为这会影响他的战略吗？就因为他认为上帝与我同在，他就要改变作战方式，把一切押在孤注一掷的一搏上？还是说他只是觉得，唯一的办法其实就是把一切押在孤注一掷的一搏上，而且上帝也与我同在，所以这也妙不可言？嗯，我认为两者兼有。
Right. I mean, it is excruciatingly dangerous, but he has no choice. I think he knows how formidable the resources that England commands are. And he, I think doesn't trust his capabilities to defeat them. Yeah. With winter closing in. So therefore he has to have the battle. Yeah.
没错。我的意思是，这极其危险，但他别无选择。我认为他深知英格兰所掌握的资源是多么强大。而且我认为他并不信任自己能够击败他们，尤其是在冬天即将来临之际。因此，他必须进行这场决战。是的。
I was wondering about that. Cause the harrying and stuff, you can do that if you've got a base to go back to. But if he doesn't really have a base and he doesn't have a heartland there, you know, that's a kind of weird strategy to just be rampaging randomly around the country with nowhere to, to hole up in, I guess. Right. He needs to bring the English to submit before winter kicks in. And there's a further dimension to this, which is that there's a kind of game of bluff and double bluff being played between William and Harold, because of course, Harold has been on a spying mission
我一直在想这个问题。因为袭扰之类的战术，如果你有一个可以撤回的大本营，那是可行的。但如果他 realmente 没有大本营，也没有一个核心根据地，你知道，到处乱跑、无处安身，这其实是一种挺奇怪的战略，我想。没错。他需要在冬天到来之前迫使英格兰人臣服。这里还有一个更深层次的维度，那就是威廉和哈罗德之间存在一场虚张声势与反向虚张声势的博弈，因为当然了，哈罗德曾去诺曼底进行过间谍任务。
to Normandy. So he has seen the Norman way of war. He is going to act on his expectations as to what the Normans will do, and what Harold thinks the Normans will do is to send their horsemen fanning out across the heartlands of Wessex, plundering granaries, seizing the harvest, torching villages, and rough and ready castles being built along the kind of the trace lines of all this devastation. That is Harold's nightmare. And when the news is brought to him in York, that must be what he immediately thinks is going to happen. And so he thinks, you know, he's got to spare his folk and fold and his people and his native
所以他见识过诺曼人的战争方式。他会根据对诺曼人行动的预期来采取行动，而哈罗德认为诺曼人会做的是：派遣骑兵深入韦塞克斯的核心地带，掠夺粮仓、抢收庄稼、焚烧村庄，并在所有这些破坏路线的沿途修建简易的城堡。这就是哈罗德的噩梦。当这个消息传到约克时，他脑子里立刻想到的肯定就是这种事会发生。因此他认为，自己必须保护他的民众和他的祖国免受这种命运的荼毒。我想我们可以想象，威廉其实是在智胜他，心想：没错，哈罗德就是这么想的。这正是引诱他上钩的方法，
land from such a fate. And I think it's possible to imagine that William is kind of outsmarting him and thinking, yeah, that is what Harold will think. That is what will draw himself. That is what will lure him into staking all on a pitch battle that actually Harold otherwise probably would not have risked. Right. So because it does seem weird that Harold, when he's got his men are exhausted, the whole of the country is with him, that he doesn't just wait.
这正是诱使他孤注一掷进行一场正面对决的方法，而哈罗德在其他情况下可能根本不会冒这个险。没错。因为这确实显得很奇怪：哈罗德明明部下已经精疲力竭，整个国家都支持他，为什么他不干脆等等呢？我想他当时在想：我实在承担不起让他在乡间横行霸作的后果，而且还有一个收成的问题，对吧？他们还没来得及收割庄稼，一切都延迟了。如果人们开始挨饿，那么这就会动摇他政权的合法性，所有这些因素肯定也在他的脑海中盘旋。
And I suppose he's thinking, you know, I just can't afford to have him rampaging around the countryside and you know, and there's also this issue of the harvest, right? They haven't brought in the harvest, that everything is delayed. If people start to starve, then, you know, that will undermine the legitimacy of his regime, all of that kind of thing. So that must be playing on his mind as well.
所有的史料都一致认为，哈罗德从约克以极快的速度返回。当他到达伦敦时，他并没有等待他所召集的军队。他不准备坐以待毙。他的母亲和他的兄弟格思里都敦促他推迟进军，但他不肯。我认为其中的原因是他想把威廉死死困住。而威廉之所以停留在原地，正是因为威廉料定哈罗德会这么做。没错。
All the sources agree that Harold returns from York at a pretty furious pace. And when he reaches London, he does not wait for troops that he has summoned. He's not prepared to sit it out. And both his mother and his brother, Gareth, urge him to delay his advance, but he won't. I think the reason for that is that he wants to keep William bottled up. And the reason that William is staying where he is, is because William is thinking that this is what Harold is going to be doing. Right.
所以我觉得威廉在智商上压倒了哈罗德。我说哈罗德，他身边有他的兄弟格思里。他身边有他的兄弟莱夫温。我不认为他身边有埃德温和莫卡。也许他有。目前尚不清楚。他们的存在没有被提及。把他们留在北方是合情合理的。我的意思是，北方才刚被收复。是的，我也这么觉得。无论如何，他决定接受这个诱饵。他要去
So I think William is outsmarting Harold. I say Harold, he has his brother Gareth with him. He has his brother, Leif Wine with him. I don't think he has Edwin andifwine with him. I don't think he has Edwin and Morka with him. Maybe he does. It's not clear. Their presence isn't mentioned. Makes sense to lead them in the North. I mean, the North's only just been recaptured. Yeah, I think so. Anyway, he decides that he's going to accept the bait. He's going
面对威廉。因此，在 10 月 13 日的傍晚，侦察兵骑马狂奔进诺曼军营，报告说在远处看到了白色的尘土，篡位者正在逼近。天哪，太令人兴奋了。这里有趣的是，你刚才说威廉智胜了哈罗德，但哈罗德却抢先一步压倒了威廉。他抵达的速度远远快于威廉的预期。
to go and confront William. And so it is on the evening of the 13th of October that scouts come galloping into the Norman camp reporting that white dust has been seen in the distance and the usurper is closing in. Crikey, it's exciting. And the interesting thing here is that you say William has outsmarted Harold, but Harold has stolen a march on William. He's arrived far, far more quickly than William expected.
我的意思是，上一集中，我们对哈罗德行军赶往斯坦福桥的速度产生了一点怀疑，不是蔑视，而是抱有一点点怀疑。但现在回程时，他真的打破了所有的陆地速度纪录。你知道，我们现有的资料表明，威廉对此确实感到非常不安。诺曼军营里一片混乱。他们没想到撒克逊人会来得这么快。是的，所以他不得不召回所有外出搜寻食物的人。他匆忙给部下下达了当晚准备战斗的命令。因此，当暮色降临诺曼军营时，这里被喧嚣与混乱所笼罩。据说，威廉把他的锁子甲穿反了。再次，这被视为一个潜在的不祥之兆。
I mean, in the last episode, we poured a little bit of skeptic, not scorn, but we were a tiny bit skeptical about some of the stories about Harold's speed going up to Stamford Bridge. But coming back down, he really has kind of beaten all land speed records. And you know, the sources we have suggest that William is genuinely discomfited by this. There's a lot of confusion in the Norman camp. They didn't expect the Saxons to arrive so quickly. Yeah, so he has to call back all the people out foraging. He gives his men a kind of hurried command to prepare for battle that evening. And so as dusk settles over the Norman camp, it's swept by clamor and confusion. And William, it is said, puts his mail shirt on the wrong way. And again, this is seen as a potentially a bad omen.
但威廉和哈罗德之间下棋般的博弈仍在继续，因为威廉并没有留在黑斯廷斯，而是决心尝试出其不意地袭击哈罗德。因此，他对部下说的是：沿着黑斯廷斯的路出发，尽管当时天色已晚，沿着这条路前进（两旁都是沼泽），离开黑斯廷斯及其城堡、船只以及逃回海峡的机会，深入内陆，试图在英格兰人准备好战斗之前与他们相遇。
But the sense in which William and Harold are playing chess with each other continues because William, rather than staying in Hastings, he is now resolved to try and take Harold by surprise. So what he says to his men is to take the road from Hastings, even though it is now getting dark, to advance along this road, you know, with the marshes on either side and to go out from Hastings with its castle, with its ships, with its opportunities for, you know, escaping back across the channel, to go inland and to try and meet the English before the English are ready for battle.
于是他们在夜色中行军了三、四、五英里，稳步前进；在他们右侧浓密的树林之外，天空渐渐发白，黎明破晓，依然不见敌人的踪影。然后，大约在八点钟，出现了你从《卡门》中读到的那个不可思议的场景：英格兰人从树林中涌上山丘，他们的长矛闪闪发光。我想很难不想象，威廉在那一刻——就像你可能会说的那样，如果你在 Aventus 中这样做过——脸上或许会浮现出一丝狼一般残酷而隐秘的微笑。
So they marched through the night three, four, five miles and steadily to their right beyond the dense woods on their flank the sky is lightning, dawn breaks, still no sign of the enemy and then at around eight o'clock this incredible scene that you read from the Carmen, the sight of the English emerging from a wood onto a hill, their spears glittering. And I think it's hard not to imagine that William at that moment, as you might have said, if you've done this in Aventus in Time, permitted himself perhaps a thin, wolfish smile.
是的，他冰冷的眼中闪烁着贪婪的光芒。因为他看到的是，哈罗德的部下仍在集结。他们还没有拉开战斗队形。显然，他们以为自己还有时间向黑斯廷斯推进，给诺曼人一个出其不意。但相反，是诺曼人给英格兰人来了个出其不意。威廉没有丝毫犹豫。他派遣弓箭手，派遣骑兵冲向英格兰人正在集结的山丘，而此时他们甚至还没有
Yeah, his cold eyes glittered with greed. Because what he is seeing is that Harold's men are still assembling. They haven't drawn up their battle line. And clearly they are assuming that they're going to have time to advance on Hastings and take the Normans by surprise. But instead it's the Normans who have taken the English by surprise. And William doesn't hesitate. He sends his archers, he sends his horsemen towards the hill on which the English by surprise. And William doesn't hesitate. He sends his archers, he sends his horsemen towards the hill on which the English are massing and they haven't yet kind of formed
排好盾墙。因此，在盾墙完全成型之前，他们极易受到箭雨的攻击，以削弱他们的战斗力。这是公元 1066 年 10 月 14 日上午 8 点刚过，黑斯廷斯战役已经打响。天哪，在过去 750 集的《历史的余烬》中，我们经历过许多悬念，但这绝对是英格兰历史上最伟大的悬念。休息过后，我们将为您揭晓黑斯廷斯战役的结局。黑斯廷斯战役。据说尤利乌斯·恺亚用月桂花环来掩饰秃顶，但在公元 2025 年，你不需要植物，你需要 Manual。
their shield wall. So they are very vulnerable to arrows to see what can be inflicted on them before the shield wall is fully formed. It is shortly after 8am on the 14th of October 1066 and the Battle of Hastings has begun. Crikey, we've had a lot of cliffhangers on The Rest is History in the last 750 episodes, but surely this is the greatest cliffhanger in all English history. Return after the break to discover what happens at the Battle of Hastings. the Battle of Hastings. They say Julius Caesar wore a laurel wreath to hide his baldness, but in AD 2025, you don't need foliage, you need manual.
Manual 正在革新脱发治疗，将科学、技术与医疗专业知识相结合，为您提供个性化方案。无论你发现枕头上多了几根头发，还是稀疏的头发像罗马军团一样向前推进，Manual 都能为脱发各个阶段提供治疗方案。加入已经加入战斗的 45,000 名男士的行列吧。92% 的人在接受治疗后看到改善，药物在短短两天内送达，3 到 6 个月内即可见效。只需回答几个关于你脱发情况和病史的问题，英国持牌专家
Manual is revolutionising hair loss treatment, combining science, technology and medical expertise to deliver personalised plans. Whether you've noticed a few extra hairs on the pillow or your thinning hairs advancing like a Roman Legion, manual offers treatments for all stages of hair loss. Join the 450,000 men already in the fight. 92% saw improvement with treatment arriving in just two days and results in as little as three to six months. So just answer a few questions about your hair loss and history and a UK licensed expert just answer a few questions about your hair loss and history and a UK licensed expert will tailor a plan and track your progress. Go right now to manual.co forward
就会为你量身定制方案并追踪你的进展。立即访问 manual.co 顺斜杠 history 开始吧，行动时你将获得首单 55% 的优惠。是的，通过 manual.co 顺斜杠 history 开始时，首单可享 55% 的优惠。Manual 男士健康，本该如此。在一切悬而未决、充满不祥预感、死亡的恐怖阴影仍等待着在战场上开始肆虐之际，一名灵魂伟大、英勇无畏的诺曼骑士，骑马走到了公爵那数不胜数的军队前面。他向法国士兵大声说着鼓励的话，同时挫伤了英格兰人的士气。接着，他将宝剑高高抛向空中，玩起了杂耍。一个英国人看到这个孤零零的身影从密集的
slash history to get started and when you do you'll get 55% off your first order. Yes that is 55% off your first order when you get started at manual.co slashslash history manual men's health the way it should be. With everything hanging in ominous suspense and the dread scourge of death still waiting to start its reaming of the battlefield, a Norman knight, great-souled and valiant in the extreme, rode out before the countless army of the duke. He cried out words of encouragement to the men of France and dampened the spirits of the English. Then, tossing his sword up high into the air, he juggled with it. A certain Englishman, witnessing the solitary figure emerge from the serrid ranks of the
诺曼队列中走出来，还拿着剑耍杂耍，心中燃起了身为军人应有的豪情。他全然不顾自己的性命，猛地冲上前去迎接死亡。那个名叫泰亚费尔（Tyaffaire）的杂耍艺人，在英国人进入射程时拍马迎了上去。他用锋利的骑枪刺穿了英国人的盾牌，并用宝剑砍下了倒地者的头颅。然后，他转身面向战友们，举起他的战利品，向他们展示他们已经在开战之初拔得头筹。
Normans and make sport with his sword, was fired with the ardour proper to a soldier. Scorning his own life, he sprang forward to meet his death. The juggler, who went by the name of Tyaffaire, spurred his horse forwards as the Englishman came within range. He ran the Englishman's shield through with his sharp-headed lance, and hacked off the head from the fallen body with his sword. Then, turning towards his fellow warriors, he lifted up his trophy, and demonstrated to them that they had had the best of the opening of the battle.
众人欢呼雀跃，同时向主祈祷——根据《黑斯廷斯战役之歌》（《卡门》）作者的说法，黑斯廷斯战役就是这样拉开帷幕的。汤姆，这听起来确实让我觉得像是一个我在过去几千年里听过无数次的战场故事，但你这一次在自己的节目中却表现得相当不寻常，你没那么持怀疑态度了。很显然，这里面存在问题，因为我们知道，战役实际上是以威廉的弓箭手向英格兰人尚未排好的盾墙倾泻箭雨开始的。
All rejoiced, and at the same time called upon the Lord so that according to the author of the song of the Battle of Hastings the Carmen was how the Battle of Hastings began and again Tom it does have to me the quality of a story that I think I've heard many times before in battle stretching back thousands of years but you are for once very unusual in your own episodes, you are less skeptical. Well clearly there are problems with it because we do know that the battle actually begins with Williams archers raining arrows on the unformed shield wall of the English.
正如你所说，泰亚费尔的杂耍听起来像是你在骑士传奇中才会读到的情节。事实上后来的记述将其写得更加直白。其中一份记述说，泰亚费尔在查理曼和罗兰公爵面前歌唱——你知道的，那是法国广为流传的关于骑士精神和骑士风度的宏大史诗——他是在有意识地模仿那个。好吧，这在普瓦捷的威廉的著作中确实是一种显而易见的倾向，他总是把威廉不与骑士传奇中的人物相提并论，而是与古代的历史人物作比较。后来的历史学家也这么做。因此威廉·马姆斯伯里就有一个
And as you say, Tyaffa's juggling sounds like something that you get from a chivalric romance. And in fact, later accounts of it make it explicit. So one of them says that Tyaffer sang before the Duke of Charlemagne and Roland, you know, this great epic of chivalry and knighthood that was so popular in France that he's consciously modeling himself on that. And this, okay, is a trend that you definitely see in William of Poitiers, who is always comparing William not so much to figures from chivalric romance, but to figures from antiquity. And later historians do that too. So William of Malmesbury, there's
绝对经典的例子。他描述了威廉如何从船上走下来，蹚过英格兰的海水登上佩文西的海滩，当他登陆时绊倒了，一个看着他的骑士说：“没关系。看，他手里抓着沙子。他已经把英格兰握在手中了。”这呼应了苏埃托尼乌斯所著《恺撒传》中的一个场景，尤利乌斯·恺撒做了完全相同的事。这很可能影响了斯诺里对哈罗德·哈德拉达记述中的相似故事。所以你会觉得这类情节在不断地被循环使用。萨迦有点像詹姆斯·邦德电影，这里面确实有一点这种成分，
an absolutely classic example. He describes how William steps out from his ship, wades through the English waters onto the beach at Pevensey and that as he lands, he stumbles and a knight watching him says, it's all right. Look, he is holding up sand in his hands. He has England in his grasp. And this echoes a scene from Sotonius's Life of Julius Caesar, where Julius Caesar does exactly the same. And it may well influence a similar story in Snorri's account of Harold Hardrada. So there's a sense of these kind of episodes being recycled and recycled. The sagas are a little bit like Bond films and there's a slight element of this here,
不是吗？也许吧，但还有另一种解释，那就是也许诺曼人确实有意识地受到了骑士传奇或尤利乌斯·恺撒生平等作品的影响，而这反过来又影响了他们的行为。你可能会说，正因为遭遇战如此罕见，它恰恰是扬名立万的绝佳机会。而且，再次重申一遍，这首《卡门》很可能是黑斯廷斯战役后仅仅几个月内写成的。
isn't there? Possibly, but there is an alternative explanation, which is maybe the Normans are actually knowingly influenced by say, chivalric romance or the lives of Julius Caesar or whatever, and that it's impacting their behavior. And you might say that the pitch battle precisely because it is so rare is the perfect opportunity to make a name for yourself. And again, just to reiterate, the Carmen is written probably only a few months after the Battle of Hastings.
不是吗？有可能，但还有另一种解释，也就是诺曼人可能确实受到了诸如骑士传奇或尤利乌斯·凯撒生平等事迹的有意影响，从而对他们的行为产生了影响。你可能会说，主力会战正是因为如此罕见，所以是扬名立万的绝佳机会。再次重申，《卡门史诗》大概是在黑斯廷斯战役后仅仅几个月写成的。
Is it likely he'd have made it up completely? I don't know. So I am less skeptical about this than I might normally be. And I like the idea, you know, that Knights and maybe even William himself are consciously modeling themselves on figures from the past. And it is interesting that again and again, William is being compared to Julius Caesar because of course Julius Caesar had led a successful invasion of Britain. I don't know. Well, people always have models at the back of their minds, don't they, that they try to live up to.
他完全是凭空捏造的吗？我不知道。所以我对这件事的怀疑程度，可能没有平时那么高。而且我很喜欢这个想法，你知道的，那就是骑士们，甚至威廉本人，都有意识地在模仿过去的人物。有趣的是，威廉一次又一次地被拿来与尤利乌斯·凯撒作比较，因为当然，尤利乌斯·凯撒曾率领军队成功入侵过不列颠。我不知道。好吧，人们的脑海深处总是会有一些试图去效仿的榜样，不是吗？
And as you point out in your notes, everybody who goes into this battle, they'd fought in battles before, but they also have an image in their minds of how they think people ought to behave in battles and they're conscious of themselves. They're conscious that behind them are centuries of tradition and history and heroism and whatnot. So we talked about how Howard Hardrada had his great banner, the land waster. I mean, Harold Godwinson has his banner and that in itself is a kind of, I don't want to say a kind of cosplay, but you know, you have a brilliant banner because that's what you think people do and he's got his fighting man, hasn't he? Yes. And also the Wyvern. Yes, so the Wyvern is a two-legged dragon and
正如你在笔记中指出的那样，所有参加这场战役的人，他们以前都打过仗，但他们的脑海中也有一个形象，关于他们认为人们在战斗中应该如何表现，而且他们对自己的行为有清醒的认识。他们意识到，在他们身后是几个世纪的传统、历史、英雄主义等等。所以我们谈到哈拉尔·哈德拉达有他的伟大战旗——“土地荒芜者”。我的意思是，哈罗德·戈德温森也有他的战旗，这本身就是一种，我不想说是一种角色扮演，但你知道的，你有一面耀眼的战旗，因为那是你认为人们会做的事，他有他的“战斗战士”，对吧？是的。还有双足飞龙。是的，所以双足飞龙是一种两条腿的龙，
again, this is a banner that reaches back centuries. So just as the Normans may well be modeling themselves on figures from ancient Rome, Harold is drawing on traditions that derive from his Danish side. His mother is Danish, the fighting man, the banners, all this kind of stuff. But also these are traditions that reach back centuries and centuries in Wessex. And on both sides, the combatants are aware of themselves as protagonists in very, very ancient traditions. That is why it is hard, I think, to distinguish the element of overt melodrama from the narratives, because I think that many of the fighters are themselves kind of consciously playing with that.
同样，这也是一面历经数个世纪的战旗。因此，正如诺曼人可能在模仿古代罗马的人物一样，哈罗德也在汲取源自他丹麦血统的传统。他的母亲是丹麦人，战斗战士、战旗，所有这些诸如此类的事情。但这些也是威塞克斯历经几个世纪的传统。双方的参战者都意识到自己是古老到不能再古老的传统中的主角。这就是为什么我认为很难从叙事中区分出明显的戏剧化成分，因为我认为许多战士本身就在某种程度上是有意识地在演绎这种戏剧性。
Right. Yeah. The other thing about Harold's banners, we know that they are definitely there because they are described as being planted on the highest point of the hill below which the Norman army is gathered. And in due course, Harold will die there and William will build a great Abbey and the altar of this Abbey will be planted on the site where Harold died. That is the one kind of aspect of the English dispositions that we can be relatively confident in. But what about the rest of the English army? How are they kind of drawn up? And this is very, very
对的。是的。关于哈罗德战旗的另一件事是，我们知道它们确实存在，因为它们被描述为插在诺曼军队集结的山丘下方的最高点上。不久之后，哈罗德将在那里死去，威廉将建造一座大修道院，这座修道院的祭坛将建在哈罗德倒下的地方。这是我们可以相对确定的英军部署的唯一一个方面。但是英军的其他部分呢？他们是如何排兵布阵的？这是一个非常、非常
contested. It's a topic that's been kind of a live one for well over a century. So Freeman, the Regis Professor of History at Oxford, who we opened this whole series with, he thought that the English battle line stretched from the summit of the hill all the way down the slope to a valley at the foot of the hill where there was very boggy terrain. And that's one theory. The other theory, which became much more popular in the 20th century, is that the English were bunched on the crest of the hill and that their flanks were kind of protected by the rough vegetation that the author of the Carmen mentioned specifically. And opinion on this has kind of swung this way in that. And I would say probably the
充满争议的问题。这是一个已经争论了一个多世纪的热门话题。因此，我们在本系列开篇时提到过的牛津大学雷吉斯历史学教授弗里曼认为，英格兰的战线从山顶一直延伸到山脚下的山谷，那里有非常泥泞的地形。这是一种理论。另一种在20世纪变得更加流行的理论是，英格兰人聚集在山脊上，他们的侧翼受到了《卡门》作者特别提到的那些杂乱植被的保护。人们对此事的看法也是摇摆不定。我想说的是，
consensus is shifting back to the idea that the English battle line wasn't just on the hill but went right the way down to this kind of slightly boggy valley. And that is under the influence of Michael Lawson's definitive book on the battle came out in 2002, mentioned it several times and he points out the common explicitly states that the English occupied the valley as well as the hill. I've mentioned that the hill is called Senlac. There are historians who say, well, this is a totallylac. There are historians who say, well, this is a totally made up name. It's very late, improbable that this was the name by which it was known. And they point out that Sorn Lac, I mean, it could be a lake
共识正在重新回到这种观点：英格兰的战线不仅在山上，而且一直延伸到了这个稍微有些泥泞的山谷。这是在迈克尔·劳森2002年出版的关于这场战役的权威著作的影响下形成的，我们已经多次提到过它，他指出《卡门》明确声明英格兰人既占领了山谷也占领了山丘。我提到过这座山被称为森拉克（Senlac）。有些历史学家说，嗯，这是一个完全杜撰的名字。这个名字出现得很晚，不太可能是当时人们所熟知的名字。他们指出“Sorn Lac”，我的意思是，它可能是一个血湖。
of blood. So it could be a name that is applied to it after the battle. But Lawson suggests that in old English, it would mean Sandy Brook and that perhaps this is what the English were defending at the foot of the hill. Because right to this day, if you go to the battlefield, you'll find that the foot of the hill is kind of very boggy. And he points out as well that there's evidence in the Bay of Tapestry, which has a scene in which French cavalry are being brought down by what look like stakes in a body of water. So the implication of that, if Lawson is right, is that Harold's army must have been pretty large. I mean, you know, numbering in the tens of thousands. It is true that the English sources that are written in the early 12th century, so William
所以它可能是一个在战后才被赋予的名字。但劳森认为，在古英语中，它的意思是“沙溪”（Sandy Brook），也许这才是英格兰人在山脚下奋力防守的地方。因为直到今天，如果你去到战场，你会发现山脚下的地形非常泥泞。他还指出，贝叶挂毯上有证据表明，画面中法国骑兵被水体中看起来像是木桩的东西击落。因此，如果劳森是对的，这就意味着哈罗德的军队规模必定相当庞大。我的意思是，你知道的，人数达数万人。的确，写于12世纪早期的英国史料，比如马姆斯伯里的威廉、亨廷顿的亨利，所有这些我们提到过的人，都说哈罗德的军队规模很小，相对于诺曼人来说很小。但我认为你不得不说他们会这么说，因为他们不想承认一支庞大的英格兰军队被全歼了。
of Malmesbury, Henry of Huntington, all these people we've had cause to mention, they say that Harold's army is small, that it's small relative to the Normans. But I think you'd have to say they would say that because they don't want to admit that a large English army has been wiped out. Right. And it is certainly the case as we've talked about before, that it is well within the capabilities of the English state to summon an army in tens of thousands. Yeah. And even though we're told that Harold, you know, he didn't wait for all the men that could have come, even so I think there's no reason to doubt that he could have been in command of a really sizable army. But the honest truth is, is that certainty on this is impossible.
对的。而且正如我们以前讨论过的那样，英格兰国家完全有能力召集一支数万人的军队。是的。尽管我们被告知哈罗德，你知道的，他没有等待所有本可以赶来的士兵，即便如此，我认为没有理由怀疑他当时能够指挥一支规模相当可观的军队。但老实说，要对此确信是不可能的。
We just don't know. Do you know what baffles me about historians of battles? It's always baffled me. They hate saying we don't know. They'll spend decades fussing about like whether they're standing on this side of the field or that side of the field. I mean, come on, who cares? We know how the battle ended and that's what matters.
我们就是不知道。你知道战役历史学家有什么让我感到迷惑的地方吗？这总是让我感到迷惑。他们讨厌说“我们不知道”。他们会花上几十年时间为诸如“他们是站在战场这一边还是那一边”之类的事情争论不休。我的意思是，拜托，谁在乎呢？我们知道战役是如何结束的，这才是最重要的。
I know it's a weird thing to say about other historians, but this sort of battle, this mad battle pedantry when you cannot possibly know just fills me with total bewilderment. Well, but I think also with Hastings, there is one thing that we definitely know, which is that the English have occupied a position which William and his forces find impossible to outflank. So I think that's kind of the debate. You have to explain how and why that is the case.
我知道对其他历史学家说这种话很奇怪，但这种战役，这种当你根本不可能知道时的疯狂战役学究气，只会让我感到彻底的迷惑。嗯，但我也认为，对于黑斯廷斯战役，有一件事是我们绝对知道的，那就是英格兰人占据了一个让威廉及其军队发现根本无法迂回侧翼的位置。所以我认为这才是争论的关键所在。你必须解释这是如何以及为什么会这样的。
Right. Because clearly that is the key to the whole course of the battle. The English are on this Hill, right? And dislodging them is going to be a hell of a job. Plus, so if they fight and it's inconclusive, which a lot of battles can be quite inconclusive, can't they? That's a bad blow for William because he really only has one go at this. Effectively Harold has then won I think okay
对的。因为很显然，这才是整场战役进程的关键。英格兰人在这座山上，对吧？要把他们赶走可是一项艰巨的任务。此外，如果他们开战却难分胜负，而很多战役往往会打成平手，不是吗？这对威廉来说是个沉重的打击，因为他其实只有这一次机会。实际上，那就意味着哈罗德赢了，我想，好吧。
Yeah, this is a tragic story. This is so the job of the English is to hold the hill Yeah, and by holding the hill you're blocking the advance along on the road to London Yeah, you're bottling the Normans up and if you hold the hill then you can wait for reinforcements and you can wait for that fleet That is sailing towards Hastings. There must be a part of you Tom that's tempted to change the end of the story. It makes it a better episode. Well, we'll see. There are twists still to come. But clearly the Normans know this and they know that their job is not just to clear the
是的，这是一个悲剧性的故事。所以英格兰人的任务是坚守这座山。是的，通过坚守这座山，你就阻断了通往伦敦的道路。是的，你把诺曼人堵在了里面，如果你守住了这座山，你就可以等待增援，等待那支正向黑斯廷斯驶来的舰队。汤姆，你内心深处一定有一部分很想改变故事的结局吧？这会让它成为一个更好的单集。好吧，我们走着瞧。还有转折要来。但很显然，诺曼人深知这一点，他们知道他们的任务不仅是将英格兰人清除出局，我认为更是要特地杀死哈罗德，因为哈罗德是关键。干掉他，通往英格兰王座的道路就向威廉敞开了。在1066年10月14日这一天发生的一切，这个可怕的血腥之日，我认为都是由这两个相互对立的目标决定的。英格兰防线的关键是我们已经提到过的一个东西。就是这个盾墙，受过训练的步兵，可能有好几排，甚至很多排之深。而且毫无疑问，在盾墙的最前线，英格兰步兵的武装和盔甲至少和诺曼人一样精良。所以他们有长矛，有剑，有他们著名的战斧，他们穿着锁子甲、头盔、盾牌。
English out of the way, but I think specifically to kill Harold because Harold is the key. Eliminate him and then the way to the English throne is open for William. And everything that happens on the 14th of October 1066, this terrible blood-soaked day, I think is determined by those two mutually opposed objectives. And the key to the English defence is something we've already mentioned. It's this shield wall, trained infantry, probably several, maybe many ranks deep. And certainly in the front line of the shield wall, the English infantry are at least as well armed and armoured as the Normans. So they've got spears, they've got swords, they've got their famous axes, they're wearing chainmail, helmets, shields. and even though many undoubtedly do fall to
尽管许多人在艰难组成盾墙时确实倒在了诺曼弓箭手的箭下，但一旦他们占据了位置，一旦那些盾牌锁紧，那么他们的阵地就相当、我的意思是相当强大。而且，你知道的，向诺曼人致敬，因为他们在山脚下。他们必须爬上这片非常崎岖的地形。这里有这堵盾墙。他们深知英格兰步兵有多么强大，号角齐鸣。英格兰人用武器敲击着盾牌。他们发出了响亮的战吼：Oot, Oot, Oot。
the Norman archers as they're struggling to form their shield wall, once they have taken up position, once those shields have been locked, then their position is pretty, I mean, pretty formidable. And, you know, I mean, it's cute us to the Normans because they're at the foot of the hill. They've got to go up this very rough terrain. There's this shield wall. They know how formidable English infantry is blaring of trumpets. The English are beating their weapons on the shields. They've got their brilliant war cry of OOt, OOt, OOt.
对的。我的意思是，太可怕了。就像一个加拿大人在说20，说出“out”这个词。是的。冰球队。是的。面对这种情况，诺曼人的战术是什么？他们显然也有他们的军号。
Right. I mean, terrifying. Like a Canadian talking 20, say the word out. Yes. Ice hockey team. Yeah. So what are the Norman tactics faced with this? They obviously have their war trumpets too.
他们有他们的战吼，deus a，这基本上就是“上帝站在我们这边”的意思。我觉得比起废话，它对我来说没那么有威慑力，但也差不多。此外，威廉拥有两个特别的师，也就是哈罗德所没有的两类人。这就是弓箭手，包括弩手。英格兰人没有弩手。他们似乎也没有多少弓箭手，至少在贝叶挂毯上是这样。只有一个英格兰弓箭手。当然，诺曼人有骑兵。正如《卡门》的作者在开篇段落中所说，他们把马留在了后方。所以他们有用于骑乘去战场的马，但
They have their battle cry, deus a, which is kind of basically God's on our side. I think is less intimidating than rubbish myself, but also William has two particular divisions, two particular types of men that Harold doesn't. So these are archers, including crossbowmen. The English don't have crossbowmen. They don't seem to have had many archers, certainly on the Bay of Tapestry. There's only one English archer. And of course the Normans have cavalry. And as the author of the Carmen said in that opening passage, they have left their horses at the rear. So they have horses for riding to battle, but
他们实际上并不在战斗中使用它们。关于黑斯廷斯战役如何展开的传统理解是，弓箭手向英格兰阵线发射齐射，据推测有人倒下，然后骑兵冲上山坡，试图对盾墙中因此产生的缺口造成杀伤。这就是贝叶挂毯上所描绘的。这也是“瓢虫”书中所描绘的，那是我接触这事的启蒙读物。人们几乎想当然地认为这就是当天的节奏。但再次引用迈克尔·劳森的话，他对这事持一种令人高兴的修正主义态度，他
they don't use them actually in battle. And the traditional understanding of how Hastings plays out is that the archers fire volleys at the English lines, presumably people fall and the cavalry then charge up the hill to try and inflict damage on the kind of the resulting gaps in the shield war. And this is what is shown on the Bay of Tapestry. It's what's shown in the Lady Bird book, which was my kind of introduction to this. It's pretty much taken for granted that this is the rhythm of the day. But again, to quote Michael Lawson, who's being cheerily revisionist about this, he
写道：“就骑兵而言，人们可以承认，拥有骑兵赋予了威廉哈罗德所不具备的战术选择，并且在战役的关键节点上，它可能非常重要，但这并不意味着其行动注定会起到决定性作用。”那么他是什么意思呢？他基本上在说些什么？所以他基本上是在说，骑兵很可能并没有发挥传统人们所认为的那种在战役中的关键作用。
writes, as far as cavalry goes, one can acknowledge that possession of it gave William tactical options not available to Harold and that at points in the battle, it may have been of great importance without concluding that it was inevitable that its actions would prove decisive. So what's he mean by that? What's he basically saying? So essentially what he's saying is that cavalry may well not have played the key role in the battle that traditionally people have thought.
他为此给出了各种理由。所以山很陡峭。地形很崎岖。这一点一直被强调。我认为这些情况的结合，会使得骑兵很难发起你在贝叶挂毯上所看到的的那种冲锋。还有战役持续的时间之久，因为剧透一下，它基本上从清晨一直持续到日落，整整打了一天。
And he gives various reasons for thinking this. So the hill is pretty steep. The terrain is rough. This is always being highlighted. And I think that the combination of those circumstances would have made it difficult for cavalry to make the kind of charge that you see illustrated on the Bay of Tapestry. Also the fact the battle lasts as long as it does, because spoiler, it basically, it goes on all day from, you know, early morning to sunset.
这表明，如果诺曼骑兵正在策马冲上山坡并攻击英格兰军队，他们的效率并不是很高。他们可能没有进行那种大规模冲锋，你知道的，把长矛夹在胳膊底下，以亚瑟王骑士的方式冲锋。这是一种尚未完善的战斗风格，还要记住，马匹没有穿盔甲，所以它们非常、非常脆弱，你知道的，如果它们进行近距离肉搏的话。你有一群留着八字胡、挥舞着战斧的可怕家伙。
It suggests that if the Norman cavalry are galloping up the hill and attacking the English army, they're not being very effective They are probably not doing mass charges with you know Their lances couched beneath their arms in the manner of King Arthur's Knights That's a style of fighting that hasn't yet been perfected and also bear in mind the horses are not wearing armor so they are very very vulnerable to You know if they're going up into close quarters You've got all these kind of terrifying people with their mustaches and their axes.
对的。你能哄一匹马冲上山坡去冲击盾墙的次数，也就那么几次。我的意思是，我猜这个次数大概是一次。因此，这意味着黑斯廷斯战役实际上可能比传统认为的更像是一场步兵对步兵的冲突。所以再次引用劳森的话：“尽管贝叶挂毯突出了法国骑兵，但黑斯廷斯战役之所以如此漫长且惨烈，会不会是因为大部分时间都花在了双方密集步兵之间的交锋上？这种步兵类型是盎格鲁-撒克逊人长期以来所熟悉的，而且诺曼人也保留了其斯堪的纳维亚祖先以这种方式部署步兵的实践？”
Right. It's only the same in times you can coax a horse up a hill to charge a shield wall. I mean, I would guess the number of times is probably one. And so the implication of that is that actually Hastings may have been much more of a clash of infantry against infantry than has traditionally been assumed. So again, to quote Lawson, could it be despite the prominence given by the Bay of Tapestry to the French cavalry that Hastings was so long and hard fought because much of the day was taken up by struggles between dense bodies of infantry on both sides
同样，我们无法确切知道，但我想，当你读到这段时，你会想，是的，实际上这从直觉上讲得通，仅仅是因为战役持续了那么长时间。是的，这确实说得通。因此，关于这场战役，我们可以貌似合理地说的是，长达数小时的时间里，它就像是一场橄榄球赛中的混战，或者某种老式的足球赛，人们在德比郡的村庄里踢的那种所有人都要拼命的足球，长达数小时的时间里，诺曼人不断地向这堵盾墙发起冲击，而英格兰的盾墙基本上坚如磐石。这只是一场残酷的消耗战，就像是一场在一战中却在11世纪打响的残酷消耗战，你……
of a type with which the Anglo-Saxons had long been familiar and because the Normans had retained their Scandinavian ancestors practice of deploying their foot soldiers in this fashion too? Again, we can't know for sure, but I think, I mean, when you read it, you think, yes, actually that does instinctively make sense simply because the battle goes on. So long. Yeah, that does make sense. And so what we can say plausibly about the battle is that for hours and hours, it's like a sort of a cross-dresser in a battle in a rugby match or sort of old fashion,
而且合乎情理地，它本可以以僵局告终，但事实并非如此。部分原因是因为，嗯，有一个非常著名的场景。所以给我们讲讲这个非常著名的场景，它涉及大量的脱头盔。对的。
that kind of football that people play in kind of Derbyshire villages where everybody dies, where for hours and hours, the Normans throwing themselves against this shield wall and the English shield wall is basically holding firm. And it's just a grueling battle of kind of it's world war one, but fought out in the 11th century, kind of a grueling battle of attrition and, you. And plausibly it could have ended in a stalemate, but it doesn't. And part of this is because, well, there's this very famous scene. So tell us about this very famous scene, which involves a lot of helmet removal. Right.
所以当天的基本节奏，如你所说，是没有争议的。普瓦捷的威廉总结说，这是一场闻所未闻的战斗，一方不断发动进攻和机动，另一方则像扎根在地上一样坚定防守。我认为这个体育隐喻非常好。它就像是一支足球队，你知道的，由坚固的防线组成，试图将前锋挡在外面，你知道的，就是诸如此类的。但正如你所说，随后出现了两个戏剧性的发展。
So the basic rhythm of the day, as you said, is not in dispute. William of Poitiers sums it up that it was an unheard of kind of combat with one side launching ceaseless attacks and maneuvers, the other standing firmly as they're rooted to the ground. And I think the sporting metaphor is very good. It's a football team, you know, solid wall of defense trying to keep out strikers, it's you know, all of that. But as you say, there are then two dramatic developments.
其中的第一个，我们不知道具体发生在什么时候，但大概是在经过了相当激烈的战斗之后，威廉的左翼遇到了麻烦。它在英格兰战线的打击下开始显露颓势，并开始溃败，顺着山坡逃窜。与此同时，一个谣言在诺曼阵线中传开，称威廉本人已经死了。威廉骑马赶到他的士兵正顺着山坡溃逃的地方，据称他脱下了头盔，大喊自己还活着，并成功制止了溃逃。普瓦捷的威廉在写到他的英雄时说，他坚定了士兵们的决心，然后他们以焕发的新活力重新投入了进攻。
And the first of these, we don't know exactly when it occurs, but presumably after a good deal of fighting, William's left wing is in trouble. It's flagging against the English battle line and it starts to break and run down the hill. And at the same time, a rumour sweeps the Norman lines that William himself is dead. And William rides up to where his men are running en route down the hill and he supposedly takes off his helmet he cries out that he is alive and he manages to halt the route and William of Poitiers writing about his hero says that he strengthens his men in resolve and they then return to the attack with renewed
这似乎是一次真正的溃败。但在这之后，法国人的阵线，诺曼人的阵线，似乎又崩溃了，这种情况发生了两次。我们被告知，这两次崩溃都是假装的。它们旨在引诱英格兰人离开阵地，从而使盾墙出现缺口。果不其然，英格兰人没有固守防线，而是认为这是一个彻底结束战斗的机会，于是他们追击撤退的敌人顺着山坡而下。但这却是一个陷阱，他们的阵型被打散了，现在他们成了骑在马上的诺曼人的羔羊。
vigor. So that seems to have been a genuine route. But then following that, the French lines, the Norman lines, they seem to break again, and this happens twice. And these two breaks, we're told, are feigned. They are designed to lure the English out of position so that the shield wall is broken and sure enough the English rather than holding to their defensive positions think that there is a chance to finish the battle off once and for all and they follow the retreating enemy down the side of the hill but it's a trap their ranks are broken and they are now easy prey for the Normans on their horses and this is
骑兵正是在这里真正大显身手。也许有数千人被杀。我的意思是，我们不知道，但屠杀肯定非常惨烈。这是英格兰人犯下的重大错误。人们可能还记得，我们在图尔战役中做过一单，查理·马特和法兰克人因为没有打破阵型而受到称赞，尽管他们知道自己已经赢了。同样在阿让库尔，亨利五世也没有让他的阵型崩溃，他让士兵坚守阵位。当你占据防守阵地时，打破防守阵地就是给敌人以胜利的机会。这基本上就是似乎发生的事情。据推测，这发生在下午晚些时候，因为我们知道，随着阴影拉长，太阳开始落山，战斗变得越来越激烈。
where cavalry really comes into its own. And perhaps thousands are killed. I mean, we don't know, but certainly the slaughter is very great. And this is the great error the English make. And it's an error that people may remember we did an episode on the Battle of Tor, where Charles Martel and the Franks are praised for not breaking their line, even though they know they've won. And likewise at Agincourt, Henry V does not let his line break. He keeps his men to their positions. When you're holding a defensive position, breaking that defensive position is to give the enemy the chance of victory. And that is essentially what seems to have happened. And presumably this is happening in the late afternoon because we know that as the shadows lengthen, as the sun starts to set, the fighting becomes more and more intense.
据记载，威廉有三匹战马在身下被杀。布洛涅的尤斯特修斯送给了他第四匹马，大家可能还记得，几期节目之前，正是这个人导致了戈德温家族的流放。所以他是个和戈德温以及戈德温森家族有过过节的人。因此他把自己的第四匹马送给了威廉。也正是在这个时候，哈罗德的两个兄弟莱夫温（Leofwine）和加思（Gareth）可能都被杀害了。根据《卡门》的记载，加思是被威廉本人杀死的。所以威廉的武功，我们稍后会看到。因此加思和莱夫温都死了，但即使他们被砍倒，英格兰的阵线似乎仍然在坚守。我们必须假设哈罗德在
William Wittold has three horses killed unto him. The fourth horse that he's given is presented to him by Eustace of Boulogne, who people may remember a few shows back, which precipitated the exile of the Godwins. So he's a guy who has form with the Godwins and the Godwinsons. So he gives William his fourth horse and it's now perhaps that Harold's two brothers, Leofwine and Gareth are both slain. And according to the Carmen, Gareth is killed by William himself. So William's feats of arms, we will be looking at them. So Gareth and Leifwine are both dead, but even with them cut down, it still seems that the English line is holding. And we have to presume that Harold at
此时仍然活着，因为只要他在那里，英格兰人就还有希望。到了这个时候，很显然英格兰人是赢不了了。但正如我们所说，如果他们能坚守阵地，熬过夜晚，逼平对手，那实际上就和胜利一样好。而威廉就会，你知道的，陷入孤立。他的许多士兵会受伤。他的背后是大海，还有一支舰队正朝他驶来。
this point is still alive, because it seems that as long as he is there, the English have hope. By this point, it's clear the English are not going to win. But as we've said, if they can just hold their position, win through to the night, force a draw, that effectively would be as good as a victory. And William would then, you know, he'd be isolated. Lots of his men would be wounded. He'd have the sea at his back. He'd have a fleet coming towards him.
你知道的，他承担不起这种僵局。因此，对他和诺曼人来说，干掉哈罗德是至关重要的。绝对至关重要。这就是为什么我认为哈罗德的死具有这种标志性的、几乎是传奇的品质。具有荷马史诗般的品质。具有荷马史诗般的品质，因为它确实是战役中的关键时刻，因此也是整个征服进程中的关键时刻。当然，关于他如何死的故事是整个英国历史上最著名的故事之一。有一支箭射中了她的眼睛，这个故事是从哪里来的？
You know, he can't afford this stalemate. And so it is crucial for him and for the Normans to finish off Harold. Absolutely essential. And this is why I think the death of Harold has this kind of iconic, almost legendary quality to it. Homeric quality to it. Homeric quality to it, because it really is the key moment in the battle and therefore in the whole process of the conquest. And of course, the story of how he dies is one of the most famous in all of English history. There's an arrow hits him in the eye and where does this story come from?
传说这被描绘在贝叶挂毯上。画面中有两个人物，其中一个人的眼睛里似乎中了一箭。他的手正抓着箭杆。看起来像是想把它拔出来。然后另一个人正被一个诺曼骑兵砍倒。在这两个人物上方，有拉丁文文本：Hic Harold Rex Interfectus est，这里，哈罗德国王被杀了。这就是哈罗德死于乱箭穿眼的事实证据吗？当你听到我这么说时，你可能会这么认为：大约在1080年，也就是黑斯廷斯战役后仅仅十年左右，蒙特卡西诺的一位编年史家，
So famously it is supposedly shown on the Bay of tapestry. You have two figures, one seemingly with an arrow in his eye. He's got his hand to the shaft of the arrow. It looks like trying to pull it out. And then there's another is being struck down by a Norman horseman. And above these two figures, you have the Latin text, Hic Harold Rex Interfectus est here, King Harold is killed. Is this evidence for the fact that Harold was killed by an arrow in his eye? you might think so when I tell you that around 1080, just over a decade after the Battle of Hastings, a martyr of Monte Cassino, the
那个写诺曼人有多么了不起的人，蒙特卡西诺的修士，他报道说哈罗德是在眼睛中箭后身亡的。而下个世纪的英国作家马姆斯伯里的威廉则报道说，箭头直接穿过了他的眼窝，深深刺入他的大脑，从而结果了他的性命。所以听众可能会想，好吧，这似乎是一个板上钉钉的案子，但这可是中世纪历史。显然并非如此，那可就太简单了。所以，贝叶挂毯存在一些问题。首先，这两个人物中究竟哪个是哈罗德国王？是那个眼睛中箭的，还是那个被砍倒的？
guy who wrote about how brilliant the Normans were, the monk of Monte Cassino, he reports that Harold had died after being hit in the eye. And William of Malmesbury in the following century, the English writer, he reports that the arrow point had gone straight through his eye socket and deep into his brain so that this had finished him. So listeners might think, well, this seems to be an open and shut case, but this is medieval history. Obviously, it's not that would be far too easy. So the Bay of Tapestry, there are problems with it. So first of all, which of the two figures is King Harold? Is it the one with the arrow in his eye or is it the one who's being cut down with?
人们经常说这两个场景涉及同一个人。就像连环画一样。就像连环画一样，但它们又不是，因为它们看起来不一样，对吧？它们的装备不同。它们显然不是同一个人。除非你知道，哈罗德在被箭击中后放下了一件武器又拿起了另一件，我的意思是，我不这么认为。还有一个更具破坏性的细节，那就是我们知道这幅挂毯在19世纪被非常严重地重新缝补过。我们有一幅1730年制作的插图和复制品。这表明，那个看似眼睛中箭的战士，
People often say these are two scenes involving the same person. So like a strip cartoon. Like a strip cartoon but they're not because they look different is that right? They've got different kit. They're clearly not the same person. I mean unless you know Harold's put down one weapon and picked up another after being hit by the, I mean, I don't think so. There's an even more damaging detail, which is that we know the tapestry was very heavily restitched in the 19th century. And we have an illustration, a copy of it that was made in 1730. And this shows that the warrior who seemingly has the arrow in his eye The warrior who seemingly has the arrow in his eye seems actually to be holding a spear. And obviously that is kind of problem if you're using it as evidence that Harold was hit
那个看似眼睛中箭的战士，实际上似乎正拿着一长矛。显然，如果你把它用作哈罗德眼睛中箭的证据，这就成了一个问题。编年史家，我的意思是他是1080年写的，所以这算证据吗？同样的问题在于，我们没有原始的拉丁文文本。我们只有一本晚得多的法语译本。所以同样，这可能是不可信的。有趣的是，最早的史料，也就是《卡门》和普瓦捷的威廉，对哈罗德眼中中箭一事根本没有任何提及。
in the eye. A martyr, so I mean he's writing in 1080, so is that evidence? Again a problem that we don't have the original Latin text. We only have a much later French translation. So again that may be untrustworthy. And the intriguing thing is, is that the very earliest sources, so that's the Carmen and William of Poitiers, they do not make any mention at all of the arrow in Harold's eye.
尽管马姆斯伯里的威廉确实明确提到了这一点。他确实提到了。这并不是说我们可以说，好吧，这没有发生。确实有暗示这件事发生的史料。所以，但马姆斯伯里的威廉写作时，你知道的，我的意思是那是两代人之后了。是的，但他肯定是从什么地方知道的。他不会凭空捏造，对吧？显然周围流传着各种传说。那么其他传说呢？所以普瓦捷的威廉，他写作的年代很早，是一个非常早期的史料，他对于哈罗德死的方式和方法却闭口不谈，对吧？
Although William of Malmesby does explicitly mention it though. He does. It's not like we can say, well, okay, it didn't happen. There are sources that hint that it does. So but William of Malmesbury is writing, you know, I mean two generations later. Yeah but he must have got it from somewhere. He's not gonna make it up is he? Clearly there are traditions I think floating around. So what about the other traditions? So William of Prattier who's writing, it's a very early source, he says nothing at all about the means and method of Harold's death, does he?
不，他没有提。但是，好吧，所以我们把他忘了吧。嗯，不，我们不要忘了，因为我认为，没有在夜里吠叫的狗就是一个线索。好吧，这里有一只确实在吠叫的狗。这就是你的《卡门》，你的《黑斯廷斯战役之歌》。所以你刚才说，是什么时候写的？1067年复活节。
No, he doesn't. But, yeah, so let's forget him. Well, no, let's not forget him because I think, you know, the dog that doesn't bark in the night is a clue. Well, here's a dog that does bark. This is your Carmen, your song of the Battle of Hastings. So you said, written what? Easter 1067.
很可能是。所以相当早。这个故事是？很可能是。所以相当早。是的。这个故事非常不同。所以给我们讲讲这个故事。是的。这太有趣了。所以它与传统的“箭射中眼睛”的故事非常、非常不同。所以《卡门》上说的是，威廉和布洛涅的尤斯特修斯。
Probably. So quite early. And this story is? Probably. So quite early. Yeah. And this story is very different. So tell us this story. Yeah. So this is so interesting. So it is very, very different to the traditional arrow in the eye story. So what the Carmen says is that William and Eustace of Boulogne.
所以又是那两个人，诺曼人及其法国盟友正在全力争取胜利。威廉和尤斯特修斯看到哈罗德傲然挺立，用《卡门》的原话来说，“凶猛地将那些包围他的诺曼人砍成碎片”。威廉和尤斯特修斯加入了另外两个人，这两个人都被指名道姓，四个男人在威廉的率领下，对哈罗德展开了群殴，引述《卡门》的话：“第一个，也就是威廉，用矛尖刺破盾牌，穿透他的胸膛，用喷涌的血流浸透了大地。”
So those two again, the Normans and their French allies are pressing for victory. And William and Eustace see Harold standing undaunted and to quote the Carmen, fiercely hacking to pieces those Normans who were besetting him. And William and Eustace are joined by two other men, both of whom are named two other warriors and the four men, so led by William, then attack Harold en masse and quote the Carmen. The first, that would be William, cleaving his breast through the shield with his point, drenched the earth with a gushing torrent of blood.
“第二个在头盔的防护下方砍掉了他的头，第三个用长矛刺入了哈罗德的腹部内脏。第四个砍断了他的大腿，并带走了砍下的肢体。”为了增添这一场景中暴力的普遍特质，很有可能“大腿”在该记述中是生殖器的委婉说法。所以砍下的肢体基本上就是阉割了他。对吗？是的。
The second smote off his head below the protection of the helmet and the third pierced the innards of his belly with his lance. The fourth hewed off his thigh and bore away the severed limb. And adding to the general quality of the violence of the scene is the strong likelihood that thigh is a euphemism for genitals in that account. So the severed limb is they basically castrated him. Correct? Yeah.
天哪。我希望这个版本不是真的，因为我喜欢哈罗德国王。我的意思是，我们该如何看待这件事？必须指出的是，这一记述在很大程度上被否定了，理由是如果威廉真的参与了对哈罗德的这次袭击并将其击杀，这将在整个诺曼底甚至整个基督教世界传为威震天下的武功。但这里有一个小问题，实际上，这真的是威廉希望被宣扬和歌颂的武功吗？所以有一位历史学家确实相信《卡门》中的这个故事，他对此深信不疑，并且像你多米尼克一样对它感到无比厌恶，他就是我们在19世纪末牛津大学的历史学雷吉斯教授——我们老朋友E.A.弗里曼。
Crikey. I hope that version is not true because I like King Harold. I mean, what are we to make of this? It has to be said that this account has been widely discounted on the basis that if William really had taken part in this attack on Harold and felt him, you know, this would be a feat of arms to be brooded across not just Normandy, but the whole of Christendom. But there is a slight issue because actually, is it the kind of feat of arms that William would want to be promoted and sung about? So one historian who did trust the story in the Carmen, who did believe it and was utterly
他写了这部六卷本的伟大诺曼征服史，在他的第三卷中，他讲述了黑斯廷斯战役，他评论说威廉本人似乎对发生的事情感到羞耻。弗里曼引用马姆斯伯里的威廉的话，写到了施加在哈罗德身上的残缺虐待。他写道：“这就是自诩为诺曼底骑士精神的所作所为，他们竟然这样对待一位从未对国内或国外敌人残酷或严厉过的君主。”我的意思是，威尔士人可能会对此有不同看法，但不管怎样。但我们必须对这位征服者公正地加上一句，他宣称这种最后也是最残酷的侮辱是一种卑鄙和懦弱的行为。并将行凶者驱逐出了他的军队。所以那可能就是那个据称带走了生殖器的人。我们不知道。还有一位更近的历史学家，马克·莫里斯在他的诺曼征服一书中，同样相信这个故事，并指出了更多的理由来怀疑威廉如果真的参与了对自己争夺王位伟大对手的屠杀，他为什么不想把这宣扬出去。威廉在出征时，
disgusted by it, like you Dominic, was our old friend E.A. Freeman, the Regis Professor of History at Oxford in the late 19th century. He wrote this great six volume history of the Norman conquest and in his third volume which recounts the Battle of Hastings he observes that William himself seems to have been ashamed of what had happened. And citing William of Malmesbury Freeman writes about the mutilations inflicted on Harold. He writes, such was the measure which the boasted chivalry of Normandy meted out to a prince who had never dealt harshly or cruelly by either a domestic or a foreign foe. I mean, the Welsh
打着一面由教皇本人亲自赐予的战旗。我们讨论过这有多么争议，教皇对入侵一个基督教国家的支持。而威廉如果砍倒并屠杀了一位受膏的国王，只会招致更多的批评。多米尼克，你描述过圣奥拉夫之死，在斯蒂克兰的殉难。实际上，对奥拉夫之死的描述与之非常相似。是的，被他的敌人包围，卡尔维努斯和戴着魔法斗篷的托林。他们刺死他，然后那个家伙把长矛刺进他的腿，然后是肩膀，诸如此类。
might disagree with that, but whatever. But we must add injustice to the conqueror that he pronounced the last and most brutal insult to be a base and cowardly act. And he expelled the perpetrator from his army. So that would be the guy who supposedly carrying off maybe the genitals. We don't know. And there is a more recent historian, Mark Morris in his book on the Norman conquest, who likewise believes the story and points out further reasons for doubting that William, if he really had taken part in the butchery of his great rival for the throne, why he would not have wanted it proclaimed abroad. William is fighting
这将是一个有趣的说法。你认为圣奥拉夫之死是以现实生活中哈罗德之死为蓝本的吗？我认为这让人想起维京人所颂扬的那种残暴和战斗风格，这种风格在12和13世纪的萨迦中仍然受到歌颂，但在日益具有骑士精神的拉丁欧洲已经不再受到歌颂了。《卡门》中的威廉表现得像一个来自北欧史诗的英雄。他表现得不像一个骑士。因此你可以看到，黑斯廷斯战役之后，他可能有一些理由想要掩盖这件事。这甚至可能
beneath a banner that has been given him by the Pope himself. And we've talked about how this is very controversial, the papal backing for the invasion of a Christian country. And for William to cut down and butcher an anointed king would only have enhanced the criticisms. Dominic, you described the death of St. Olaf, the martyrdom at Stiklestad. And actually the description of the death of Olaf at that is very similar. Yeah, surrounded by his enemies, Calvinus and Thorin the Hound with his magic cloak. They stab him and the bloke plunges a spear into his leg and then his shoulder and all this.
是《卡门》最终被埋没这么久的原因。这有点尴尬。作者没有领会到精神。就我个人而言，我认为《卡门》的记述，由于它是最早的，比哈罗德死于乱箭穿眼的说法更可信。听起来不过瘾啊。我们喜欢箭。我想是的，但暴力的特质，我的意思是，非常、非常符合在这场战役中降临到英格兰人身上的残暴和恐怖的命运，因为随着哈罗德的死，英格兰人显然战败了。
That would be an interesting claim. Do you think that the death of St. Olaf is modeled on the real life death of Harold? I think that it's reminiscent of a kind of brutality, a style of fighting that was celebrated by the Vikings and is still being celebrated in the sagas in the 12th and 13th centuries, but is no longer celebrated in a Latin Europe that has become increasingly chivalric. William is behaving like a hero from a Norse epic in the Carmen. He is not behaving like a chivalier. And I think that you could see therefore that there might be reasons why in the wake of Hastings, he might have wanted to cover it up. And this may even
极大的可能性是，情况将会很艰难，英格兰人显然已经战败，极大的可能性是，英格兰人现在很难继续与胜利的诺曼人进行战斗了。你会注意到，我英勇地抵制了用《千年》的朗读来开启这集的诱惑，但我无法抗拒用它来结束这集的诱惑。那就开始吧。我们不知道哈罗德究竟是怎么死的。但有一件事是确定的，那就是践踏着哈罗德的诺曼骑兵，把他当作了堆在倾覆的王室战旗周围的众多尸体中的一具。
be a reason why the Carmen ends up buried for as long as it does. It's a bit of an embarrassment. The author hasn't got the memo. Personally, I think the Carmen's account, again, it's the earliest, is likelier than the fact that Harold died with an arrow in his eye. Sounds really not as good though. The arrow, we love the arrow. I suppose, but the quality of brutality, I mean, is very, very true to the brutality and horror that is the fate of the English in the battle, because with Harold dead, the English are clearly defeated.
只是在屠杀之日众多倒下的牺牲品中的一个，这场屠杀足以让斯坦福桥战役都黯然失色。随着夜幕降临，残存的英格兰人终于转身逃入渐浓的夜色中，在整个夜晚遭到威廉兴高采烈的骑兵的追捕。血腥味和被掏空的内脏的恶臭，连同伤员的呻吟和啜泣，成了这场屠杀的最直接见证。威廉赌赢了，他胜利了。
And the strong probability is that it's going to be difficult, the English are clearly defeated and the strong probability is that it's going to be difficult for the English to carry on the fight now against the victorious Normans. You'll note that I heroically resisted the temptation to open this episode with a reading from Millennium, but I can't resist the temptation to finish it. So go for it. We don't know how Harold died exactly. But one thing is certain that Norman Horseman, trampling Harold down, left him as just one among a heap of corpses piled around the toppled royal banner.
如果你现在收听节目却还不是“历史的其余部分”俱乐部的会员，你知道该怎么做。你在therestishistory.com注册。再见。再见。
Just one among the fallen on a day of slaughter fit to put even Stamford Bridge into the shade. As darkness fell and what was left of the English turned at last and fled into the gathering darkness to be hunted throughout the night by William's exultant cavalry. It was the reeking of blood and emptied bowels together with the moans and sobs of the wounded that bore prime witness to the butchery. William had gambled and he had won. right now and you're not a member of the Rest is History Club, you know what to do. You sign up at therestishistory.com. Goodbye. Goodbye. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
本集暂无评论。点击转录文本中的任意句子即可发表评论。